is trying out the gt3 rs the latest
version of porsche's best-selling 911
carrera line
rs stands for racing sports and the car
lives up to that there's lots of changes
the body is wider by 50 millimeters in
front and 30 in back
the rear wing is bigger for greater
downforce
and the front wheel air vents diverts
about one third of the down force onto
the front axle
the car puts out some 500 horsepower but
that's not all
klaus takes the gt3 out onto the
racetrack where it's truly in its
element more than any other 911 this
model gives you a pure high a real
racing feel
output is 368 kilowatts generating 460
newton meters of torque and it makes the
sprint from zero to 100 in just 3.3
seconds
in the rs you can switch off esp and
traction control entirely
but even when you leave them switched on
in the interest of safety the
performance is impressive
klaus knows he's the envy of many a
porsche fan it's not everyone who gets a
chance to take the new 911 gt3 rs out
for a spin on the bilster bag track
though it's just four kilometers long
it's a piece of work
first he turns off all the electronic
driving assistance options
and switches pdk sport on
traction control is off now it's pure
driving just him and the car
extra track width at the front and rear
axles make for enhanced stability as do
the tires the widest on any 911 model
that adds up to greater mechanical grip
and even higher speeds through the
curves
but even so klaus says this car is still
suited for everyday driving you can
cruise the highways or head off to
dusseldorf hamburg berlin or frankfurt
for shopping it's a car that fits most
every lifestyle
so despite its athleticism the 368
kilowatt output and a top speed of 310
kilometers an hour the gt3 rs is a good
all-rounder the pdk dual clutch gearbox
takes care of the shifting
says the car masters s-curves perfectly
even with the pedal to the metal and 230
kilometers per hour
downshifting for a fast left curve you
can really feel the car's excellent
balance
and that also has to do with all the
downforce
the gt3 rs is without doubt an
exceptional sports car the body includes
the aerodynamic add-ons typical of the
rs models
and the extra width really emphasizes
its motor sports pedigree
the interior design is porsche through
and through
carbon fiber sport bucket seats offer
firm support under extreme conditions
the alcantara steering wheel was taken
from the hybrid super sports car 918
spyder
in some klaus says this car drives like
a bonafide race car but you can still
take it grocery shopping the downside is
the price at almost 182 000 euros in
germany but that buys you a car that's a
joy to drive
the porsche 911 gt3 rs is a race car for
street driving it's a car with one
single goal to be the fastest car on the
road
the international ces in las vegas is
widely seen as the prime home
electronics trade fair
car cartes samantha's current is in the
chinese city of shanghai for the asian
version of the event
this is ces asia's first year with just
two exhibition halls it's nowhere near
the size of the original event but the
range of products is still broad and
varied
mata says there's no single dominant
trend at the ces asia it has a bit of
everything loudspeakers for every
situation even for use underwater
there are all kinds of wearables from
smart watches to fitness watches drones
and droves and 3d printers pretty much
anything electronic there are some
non-electronic items too like those bags
over there
many car makers and suppliers are also
here in shanghai mercedes-benz for
instance is here with itself driving
f-015 concept car
roberto
of mercedes points out that china is the
world's largest car market it's also a
market with more than 500 million
smartphone users very youthful and
dynamic so it's no surprise that ces has
come to china he says that someday soon
we'll be seeing new consumer electronic
trends coming out of china
the day before the fair mercedes-benz
hill detective for chinese reporters the
focus was on the c
e
and
s classes plus stuttgart's latest
innovations in infotainment and safety
daimler cooperated with the chinese web
services company baidu to develop the
baidu car life system which will offer a
broad range of internet services in
china
the intelligent drive simulator can
provide a real adrenaline rush
frog venomona mercedes says he's not
paying attention a pedestrian steps into
the road but he doesn't react and now
the car slams onto the brakes
all on its own
he says sorry
he just didn't see the pedestrian but
fortunately the car's stereo camera and
radar sensors detected the pedestrian
and slammed on the brakes
honey was the first car maker to exhibit
in las vegas they also opened ces asia
with a keynote speech so it's the
perfect opportunity for a world premiere
audi is using this car to develop their
battery technology and they're helping
their staff develop r d skills and these
kinds of systems
this r8 e-tron drove itself onto the
stage and it can cover 450 kilometers
using only electricity the battery can
be fully recharged in just two hours
with audi's combined charging system
that's another big step towards true
e-mobility and that's not audi's only
innovation here at the fair
mata says that at the ces las vegas audi
presented a tablet that seamlessly
integrates into the car's interior it
also meets all the requirements for
automotive use including crash safety
now audi's gone one step further and
added gesture control so all he has to
do is wave his hand to operate the
tablet connected to the front seat
w brought along an e-golf to shanghai
it can autonomously retrace a previously
learned route to a parking spot it uses
only technology that's already in the
series including a front camera and
ultrasound sensors
ces asia is a thriving transplant
bringing the las vegas electronics show
to china it successfully featured many
chinese brands and many international
ones as well
admits that he's not the greatest
drummer
but this music cat drum station might
help
you can see how it works
the display tells you where to hit and
when
and then you just have to practice
and that's exactly what matas is going
to do right now
carl's on his way this summer opel's new
city car will finally hit the street in
germany carl is touted as the bigger
brother of the opel atom offering five
doors and more storage space its trunk
can accommodate 195 liters of cargo the
carl also boasts a modern three-cylinder
engine all for a base price of less than
ten thousand euros
mazda is introducing a new suv to
germany this month the cx-3 borrows
features from the brand's other models
including a one and a half liter gas
engine from the mazda2 subcompact and
the all-wheel drive system from its
larger suv the cx-5
the cx-3 has a starting price in germany
of just under 18 000 euros
are you looking for a reasonably priced
car for day-to-day driving then this
here might be just the ticket
vinegar
it costs just four euros over 100
kilometers that's cheaper than the bus
or train the seat me eco fuel ultra
compact runs on compressed natural gas
so it's easy on the wallet and the
environment
in terms of performance the cng me is
right in between the two gasoline
versions it's not a speedster but it
offers all you need for a comfortable
ride it's more than respectable for an
environmental standout
from the side the me looks pragmatic and
down to earth but the headlights give
the front a snappy look
the sport variant has fog lights in the
bumper
front and rear have the typical sea ott
look
under the skin it shares the same dna as
the volkswagen up
although the interior isn't necessarily
luxurious the cockpit does feature an
elegant design it's well laid out and
there's a sat nav to guide the way
because it's an eco-fuel car it's a
manual transmission
reinhold says it has a small 68
horsepower engine it's a robust car with
decent acceleration good for city
driving delivering a top speed of 130
kilometers per hour on the motorway
the me still needs gasoline to warm up
the engine but after that it boasts an
average consumption of just 2.9 kilos of
cng per 100 kilometers fully tanked it
holds 11 kilos of cng
with an economical driving style that
yields a range of almost 380 kilometers
and in germany it can be refilled at one
of 900 filling stations
einhold says if you're not sure where
the next filling station is the sat nav
will tell you after 50 000 kilometers
the extra 2 000 euros for the cng engine
will have paid for itself and you'll get
a savings of about 1.5 tons of co2 in
the
from turning process dioxide
refilling the gas tank is perfectly safe
the fueling nozzles can vary a bit from
station to station but you can't
actually press the button to start
refilling until the fueling nozzle is
securely in place in germany at least
tax benefits make cng quite a bit
cheaper than gasoline
reinhold sums up the sea at me with cng
offers just 79 grams of co2 emissions
per kilometer hybrid cars need a lot of
technology to match that the engine is
robust and powerful enough for
day-to-day driving the car really shines
in the city and a full tank at less than
13 euros in germany will surely bring a
smile to your face for that you need cng
his last tip get the five-door variant
which offers easier access to the rear
bench
bmw has debuted a new motorcycle the
s-1000x
the bavarian automaker is riding high at
the moment when it comes to motorbikes
sales and profits are soaring so we've
brought an expert in to put the new bmw
through its paces stefan shetzer
he says it's his first time on board the
new bmws 1000 xr it's an adventure bike
based on the model of the s-1000r
roadster and he's keen to try it
the recent models by bmw motorhot are a
big part of their current success the
new s 1000xr is intended as a cross
between a sports and a touring bike
bmw is calling the new breed the
adventure sport the four-cylinder engine
is derived from the sport roadster
s-1000r it's a straight four-cylinder
engine with a displacement of 999 cc's
and output of 118 kilowatts
says it's an adventure sport so it's an
all-rounder that combines the sportiness
of the s-line with the qualities of a
touring bike so this bike lets you go on
long rides much like an enduro but it
also has the touring bike side combined
with a sporty dna you see through the
entire s family
the
s-1000xr also features perfect
ergonomics increased ground clearance
and optimal wind and weather protection
says the geometry of the frame was
slightly modified and adapted that
starts with a steering head where the
angle is slightly shallower
the fork is 30 millimeters longer
because the bike is higher in front
the wheelbase is quite a bit longer and
there's a new swing arm
it's 69 millimeters longer which gives
you a wheelbase that's 100 millimeters
longer in all and that gives ride
stability a boost
ability
and driver safety has also been given a
boost with electronic safety features
the rain and road modes come as standard
and help adjust the ride characteristics
to the road surface
an added extra is the pro mode which
includes the abs pro which provides
additional safety when braking in a bank
position
even when the brakes are applied sharply
the wheels don't lock up
and that reduces abrupt changes in
steering force
the major advantage of abs pro is how it
processes signals in a bank position
so you can control the bike even when
you brake on a curve and the bike stays
stable
that's true if the rider is caught off
guard and breaks very abruptly there's
no way to change the laws of physics but
this system does take advantage of all
the options
stefan schatzel is back from his test
ride so what's his impression
he says it's very sporty a bit higher
and not quite as athletic as the s1000r
it's sporty so you can't write it like a
gs
coasting in high gear won't give you rpm
but hit the gas and you'll really move
this car is a one-off and the last of
its kind it sports the vw logo but this
1954 boitler convertible is certainly no
run-of-the-mill vw
back then all vws were mass-produced
high-speed luxury vehicles were not on
the company's agenda
classic car expert christophe bauer
explains that in the early 50s vw made
just two models the robust cheap beetle
and the practical vw bus anyone who
wanted a touch of luxury ordered the
export beetle instead of the standard
one it came with a small vase on the
dashboard but soon clever coach builders
discovered the beetle as the perfect
platform for their luxury bodies
the first convertible based on the vw
beetle was made by hep muller in 1949
fellow germans carmen presented the
successful vw four-seater convertible at
almost the same time
apart from the missing roof and the
modified rear the bodies were just like
the ones for regular vw beetles
swift brothers and fritz boitler went a
step further christoph says they only
used vw's undercarriage and technology
and added a very special body
the two metal experts had already given
the first porsche 356 a smart aluminum
body in 1948 and then in 1954 they came
up with this beautiful boiler
convertible
always followed the same procedure they
topped the undercarriage with an elegant
exclusive light alloy body clients could
also opt for customized engine tuning
the boiler convertible can go from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in just 15
seconds thanks to its special compressor
a series production beetle needed around
30 seconds
krista finds this convertible a great
example of excellent workmanship and no
frills elegance the judges at the 1954
geneva motor show were certainly
impressed they awarded it the coveted
rose door
the almost perfect original condition of
the boiler convertible makes it a real
rarity the lightweight simple aluminum
body still has its original paint pretty
remarkable for a car that's over 60
years old
by 1956 the boitler brothers had built
three of these four-seater convertibles
this car is the first of its kind
as indicated by the golden rose on the
dashboard
it is also the last of its kind the
other two convertibles have vanished
without a trace
kristoff shows us the car's little
powerhouse a vw boxer engine with an
american judson compressor it fits in a
vw beetle as well as a karmann ghia he
says this double fan belt is connected
to the crankshaft and drives a small
rotor that compresses the air gas mix to
around 0.4 bar
this lets the car accelerate almost
twice as fast as one with a standard
engine
judson guaranteed that the lifespan of
the vw engine was in no way shortened by
the compressor and it certainly did give
the engine a richer sound
at the dawn of the automotive age car
manufacturers just delivered the
technology and the bodywork was done by
specialized coach builders once mass
production began these specialists
served a niche market building cars by
hand that the big names couldn't deliver
for example sporty convertibles with
reliable vw technology
and craftsmanship comes at a price
christoph points out and that meant a
price tag of 15 000 deutsche marks for
the boiler convertible in the 50s that
would have bought you two vw
convertibles or a porsche 356
convertible with a 70 horsepower engine
but that's not the main reason why only
three of these cars were built
in 1954 vw's heinrich nordhoff stopped
deliveries to boitler and other coach
builders saying we're a factory that
makes cars not just chassis
that's why just three were built and
this is the only remaining example
christoph says
let's
implant
the success of the self-supporting
monocoque body meant the end of special
editions
bodywork and chassis are integrated in
modern cars so adding a special body
shell would involve making major changes
to the vehicle architecture
but in post-war west germany
manufacturers wanted more individuality
and were inspired by exotic vehicles
like the boiler convertible
swiss coach builder boiler survived
until 1987 before vanishing from the
automotive horizon
you